So in the world of boxing, if an opponent
knows what to anticipate from his opponent,
he has an edge.
In war, if a country facing another enemy
can anticipate which side that enemy's going
to attack from, this person has an edge.
If YOU, the entrepreneur, can anticipate what
you are guaranteed to face in the world of
business, you have an edge.
So my goal today is to give you an edge over
everybody else who doesn't watch this video.
And you're smart, watching this Valuetainment
video here with me.
So, ten challenges every entrepreneur will
face.
#1: You've got to learn the 9 - 5 sacrificing
your salary.
That is a challenge you're going to face.
Let me tell you, when you go from having a
salary that's coming in, it's warm, it's fuzzy,
it's a nice, comfortable pillow, you've got
benefits, you've got all this stuff, and you
say, "I'm going to be an entrepreneur," you
have to sacrifice your salary.
Benefits, health insurance, no matter what
income, worst case scenario, you're going
to make your five grand a month.
Worse case you're going to make your eight
grand a month.
That is out the window.
You will have to anticipate this happening.
Next, is your capital management.
What do I mean by capital management?
Time clock, on how much you've saved, and
what your expenses are, you're going to hear
it constantly tick tock, tick tock, tick tock.
The way you manage your capital will allow
you to stay in business long enough to make
it as a business owner if you know how to
manage your capital properly.
It doesn't matter if you're a real estate
agent, if you're a technology company out
of Silicon Valley, or if you're running a
liquor store.
You will need to know how to manage your capital
yourself to stretch it out as long as possible.
Next, processing issues.
This looks pretty bad.
This looks like a horror movie right here.
Luis, this looks pretty intense.
It says, solve for x.
Let me tell you what that is.
You will have to process many unknown issues
that you've never experienced before.
You've never experienced before.
How do you do this?
I don't know how to work this part.
I don't know how to handle this issue before.
I never knew I needed this insurance policy
to be able to do this event at a hotel.
I never knew my requirement to be able to
get a lease in a building was this that I
have to spend another $7,000.
I never knew I needed to do this other part
that's going to cost me $17,000.
How come nobody told me about this stuff before?
Anticipation.
It's going to happen.
So if you don't know how to solve for x, these
situations you're going to go in, you're going
to have a hard time with it.
But you need to anticipate there will be many
issues, unknown issues, that you need to solve
that no one else is going to prepare you for.
Next, your team building, how are you going
to put a team together?
How good of a recruiter are you going to be?
How good are you at bringing solid talent,
operations, systems, sales, technology, compliance,
how are you going to do that?
How well are you going to do that?
Team building.
You will face that challenge, where you're
going to realize you can't do it all.
And it comes down to how well you build a
team.
Next, vision.
Casting a vision that others want to belong
to.
Casting a vision where I want to be a part
of.
You, constantly casting a vision that I can
be a part of it, a year, three years, five
years, ten years, 20 years down the line,
and my own selfish goals and desires can become
a reality based on the effort I want to put
in.
But based on the vision you keep casting that
everybody around you believes because you
keep getting closer and closer and closer
to that vision.
If you cannot cast the vision, you're going
to lose the best type of talent, if you don't
know how to cast the vision.
Next, you will be lonely.
I put a song here, Only the Lonely.
You will be lonely.
There will be many lonely nights.
There will be many days where you're going
to sit there by yourself saying, "I don't
really know if this is going to work out."
There will be many days you have no one to
call.
No family, no friend, no girlfriend, no husband,
no wife, no mom, grandma, grandpa, no one
for you to call because you can't complain
to any of them because you decided to become
an entrepreneur.
They never forced you to become an entrepreneur.
You decided.
So you call them, the last thing you want
to hear is what?
I told you not to do it!
It's going to be a tough phone call.
So there's going to be many lonely nights.
Lonely mornings, lonely decision-making process,
lonely Sundays, lonely Saturdays.
Next, tax and lawyers.
You are now paying taxes on a new code as
an entrepreneur.
You will need a CPA that knows how to transition
you from W2 to being an entrepreneur.
You will need lawyers to protect you from
business.
How do I structure the company?
LLC, C Corp, S Corp, you know, is this a Limited
Liability Partnership?
How am I going to.
. . am I doing a real-estate partnership with
a group of.
. . how am I setting this up?
You're going to need lawyers and taxes, which
means you're going to speak to CPAs and lawyers
in ways you've probably never dealt before,
and they're going to tell you some stuff that
you've never heard before.
Where in many cases you're going to sit there
and act like you know what you're talking
about, but you have no clue what they're saying,
and you kind of don't want them to think that
you don't know because they'll charge you
more, but you need to ask.
I don't understand.
Can you please explain this to me?
You will face this.
It's inevitable.
Next, you will wear many different hats.
You're just going to.
You're going to be a salesperson one day.
You're going to clean your room one day.
One day no one's cleaned the kitchen, and
you've got to do it.
No one's putting the stuff in the files.
You've got to do it.
You've got to answer the phones sometimes.
You've got to get back to a text that you
probably shouldn't be getting back to as a
CEO, but you need to because you're wearing
many different hats.
You're going to do design.
You're going to do what the website looks
like.
You may do social media.
You may do the posting.
No one knows this because you're wearing many
different hats and you have to go through
it as a person who starts a business.
Next, I'm going to knock you out.
You know what this is?
You're going to deal with people that want
to put your out of business.
And you're going to say, "how brutal is this?
You can't be this cold."
It's the world of business.
You're taking a piece of business away from
them, and they want to put you out of business.
So you're going to have a lot of competition
that are going to do whatever they can to
put you out of business.
Next one here is lifestyle change.
This is difficult for a lot of people.
Let me explain.
You're accustomed to going out on Friday nights
and Saturday nights.
And Thursday night ladies' night.
And maybe sleeping in a little bit.
And maybe working five o'clock you come home,
you watch all the games, all the playoff games,
all the soccer matches, all the football games.
You get every one of those things because
it's your lifestyle.
Your boys call you on Friday night because
you have this one spot you go to.
Saturday night is your favorite three lounges
that you go to.
Sunday you have a spot that you go to from
eight o'clock to one o'clock in the morning,
and you go to sleep at 1:30, so you can get
some rest to wake up at 7:00 in the morning.
You have all your spots that you do.
Let me prepare you, all of this is going to
change.
Your relationship with some of your friends,
is going to change.
Your daily habits, are going to change.
Some of the people that you were hanging out
with before, it's going to change.
Some of the places you used to go to before,
it's going to change.
Generally, this most people cannot handle.
Because they want to win big as an entrepreneur
and become a hero and celebrity and all this
stuff, but they want to keep this lifestyle.
So it's almost like they're not letting go
of this to go get this.
You have to let go of the lifestyle and if
you can't let go of this lifestyle if you
cannot wear multiple hats, if you cannot understand
the competition's going to want to put you
out of business, if you don't pay attention
to tax and law, if you don't realize you're
going to be lonely, if you don't constantly
cast a vision, build a team, process issues,
know that you don't have a lot of time to
left with the savings that you have, the capital
that you have, and the fact that you need
to eventually sacrifice your salary, the cushion,
the warm, fuzzy feeling of a steady salary
coming in, you're going to have a very hard
time as an entrepreneur and I highly recommend
you don't do anything to become an entrepreneur,
you stay as an employee.
So, with that being said, these are the ten
things every entrepreneur will face.
These ten challenge every entrepreneur will
face, and if you haven't already subscribed
to this channel, be sure to subscribe to this
channel.
Click on the button here.
And click on the alert to be one of the first
to receive the videos and be part of the notification
squad.
And if you've got any other challenges that
I did not mention in this video today, comment
on the bottom and share with us your challenges.
And if you're facing any of these challenges
right now, let us know which challenge you're
currently in as an entrepreneur.
Take care everybody.
Bye, bye.